PROFESSOR: I sent out
a survey this morning
about how the class
is going, what
you thought of the problem set.
And I would appreciate if you
provide me some feedback--
so things you like or don't
like about the class or about
the problem set that
was just due last night.
So I can try to adjust to make
it more interesting and useful
for all of you.
Last time we talked about
Szemerédi's graph regularity
lemma.
So the regularity
lemma, as I mentioned,
is an extremely powerful
tool in modern combinatorics.
And last time we saw the
statement and the proof
of this regularity lemma.
Today, I want to show you
how to apply the lemma
for extremal applications.
In particular, we'll see how
to prove Roth's theorem that I
mentioned in the
very first lecture,
about subsets of integers
lacking three-term arithmetic
progressions.
First, let me remind you
the regularity lemma.
We're always working
inside some graph, G.
We say that a pair of
subsets of vertices
is epsilon regular if
the following holds--
for all subsets A of X, B
of Y, neither too small,
we have that the edge
density between A and B
is very similar to the edge
density between the ambient
sets X and Y.
So we had this picture
from last time.
You have two sets.
Now, they don't
have to be disjoint.
They could even be the same set.
But for illustration
purposes, it's
easier to visualize what's
going on if I draw them
as disjoint subsets.
So there is some edge density.
And I say they're epsilon
regular if they behave
random-like in the
following sense--
that the edges are somehow
distributed in a fairly uniform
way so that if I look
at some smaller subsets
A and B, but not too small,
then the edge densities
between A and B is very similar
to the ambient edge densities.
So by most, epsilon difference.
Now I need that A and
B are not too small
because if you allow to take,
for example, single vertices,
you can easily get densities
that are either 0 or 1.
So then it's very hard to
make any useful statement.
So that's why these two
conditions are needed.
And here, the edge
density is defined
to be the number of edges
with one endpoint in A,
one endpoint in B, divided by
the product of the sizes of A
and B. And we say that a
partition of the vertex set
of the graph is epsilon regular
if, by summing over all pairs
i, j, such that vi, vj is not
epsilon regular if we sum up
the product of these
part sizes, then
this sum is at most an epsilon
fraction of the total number
of pairs of vertices.
And the way to think of this
is that there are not too
many irregular parts.
At least in the case when
all the parts are equitable.
So we should really
think about all
of them having more or less
the same size than saying
that at most an epsilon
fraction of them are irregular.
And the main theorem from last
time was Szemerédi's regularity
lemma.
And the statement is
that for every epsilon,
there exists some M--
so M depends only
on epsilon and not
on the graph that
we're about to see--
such that every graph has
an epsilon regular partition
into at most M parts.
In particular, the
number of parts
does not depend on the graph.
For every epsilon,
there is some M.
And no matter how
large the graph,
there exists a
bounded size partition
that is epsilon regular.
So the proof last
time gave us a bound M
that is quite large as
a function of epsilon.
So the last time
we saw that this M
was a tower of twos of height
essentially polynomial in 1
over epsilon.
And I mentioned that you
basically cannot improve this
bound.
So this bound is more or
less the best possible
up to maybe changing the 5.
And so in some sense, the
proof that we gave last time
for Szemerédi's graph regularity
lemma was the right proof.
So that was the
sequence of steps that
were the right things to do.
Even though they give
a terrible bound,
it's somehow the bound
that should come out.
What I want to talk
about today is,
what's a regularity
partition good for?
So we did all this work to
get a regularity partition,
and it has all of
these nice definitions.
But they are useful
for something.
So what is it useful for?
And here is the intuition.
Remember at the
beginning of last lecture
I mentioned this informal
statement of regularity lemma--
namely that there exists
a partition of the graph
so that most pairs
look random-like.
So what does random-like mean?
So random-like, there is
a specific definition.
But the intuition is that in
many aspects, especially when
it comes to counting
small patterns,
the graph in the
random-like setting
looks very similar to what
happens in a random graph--
in a genuine random graph.
In particular, if you
have three subsets--
x, y, and z--
and suppose that the three
pairs are all epsilon regular,
then you might be interested
in the number of triangles
with one vertex in each set.
Now, if this were a
genuine random tripartite
graph with specified
edge densities,
then the number of triangles
in such a random graph
is pretty easy to calculate.
You would expect
that it is around
the product of the sizes of
these vertex sets multiplied
by their edge densities.
And what we will see
is that in this case,
in that of an epsilon
regular setting,
this is also a true statement.
It's a true,
deterministic statement.
That's one of the consequences
of epsilon regularity.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Why are
we only multiplying
the sizes [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Asking, why
are we only multiplying
the sizes of x, y, and z?
So you're asking--
OK.
So we're trying to find out
how many triangles are there
with one vertex in x, one vertex
in y, and one vertex in z.
So if I put these vertices
in there, one by one,
then if this were
a random graph,
I expect that pair to be an edge
with probability dxy and so on.
So if all the edge densities
were one half, then
I expect one eighth of these
triples to be actual triangles.
And what we're saying is that
in an epsilon regular setting,
that is approximately
a true statement.
So let me formalize
this intuition
into an actual statement.
And this type of statements
are known as counting lemmas
in literature.
And in particular, let's look
at the triangle counting lemma.
In the triangle counting lemma--
so we're using the same
picture over there--
I have three vertex subsets
of some given graph.
Again, they don't
have to be disjoint.
They could overlap,
but it's fine to think
about that picture over there.
And suppose that these
three pairs of subsets--
so these three subsets-- they
are mutually epsilon regular.
Then, for abbreviation,
let me write
the sub xy to be the edge
density between x and y,
and so on for the
other two pairs.
The conclusion is that
the number of triangles--
where I'm looking at triangles
and only counting triangles
with one specified vertex in
x, one in y, and one in z--
is at least some quantity.
So there is a small
potential error
loss but otherwise the product,
as I mentioned earlier.
So it is at least this
quantity I mentioned earlier up
to a potential small
error because we're
looking at epsilon regularity.
So there could be
some fluctuations
in both directions.
A similar statement is also
true as an upper bound.
But the lower bound
will be more useful,
so I will show you the
proof of the lower bound.
But you can figure out
how to do the upper bound.
And later on we'll see a
general proof what happens,
instead of triangles, if you
have other subgraphs that you
wish to count.
So here's the intuition.
So you have a
random-like setting,
and we'll formalize
it in the setting
of epsilon regular pairs.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Where does the 1
minus 2 epsilon come from?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is, where does
1 minus 2 epsilon come from?
You'll see in the proof.
But you should think
of this as essentially
a negligible factor.
Any more questions?
All right.
So here's how this
proof is going to go.
Let's look at x and think
about its relationship to y.
It's epsilon regular.
And they claim, as
a result of them
being epsilon regular, fewer
than epsilon fraction of x.
So fewer than this many vertices
in x have very small number
of neighbors in y.
Because if this
were not the case,
then you can violate
the condition
of absolute regularity.
So if not, then let's
look at this subset, which
has size at least epsilon x.
And all of them have fewer than
that number of neighbors to y.
So these two sets--
so this set, x
prime and y, would
witness non-epsilon regularity.
So you cannot have too many
vertices with small degrees
going to x--
going to y.
OK.
Great.
And likewise, fewer
than epsilon x vertices
have a small number
of neighbors to z.
So what does the
picture now look like?
So you have this x and
then these two other sets,
y and z where I'm going to throw
out a small proportion of x
less than 2 epsilon
fraction of x that have
the wrong kinds of degrees.
And everything else in here
have lots of neighbors in both y
and in z.
And in particular, for all x up
here it has lots of neighbors
to y, lots of neighbors to z.
How many?
Well, we have at least d sub xy
minus epsilon y neighbors to y
and at least d sub xz minus
epsilon times z neighbors to z.
OK.
So now I realize I'm missing
a hypothesis in the counting
lemma.
Let me assume that none of these
edge densities are too small.
They're all at least 2 epsilon.
So now these guys are at least
epsilon fractions of y and z.
So I can apply the definition
of epsilon regularity
to the pair yz to deduce
that there are lots of edges
between these two sets.
So over here, the
number of edges
is at least the products of the
sizes multiplied by the edge
density between them.
And by the definition
of epsilon regularity,
the edge density between these
two small or these two red sets
is at least d of
yz minus epsilon.
So putting everything
now together,
we find that the total
number of triangles,
looking at all the possible
places where x can go--
so at least 1 minus 2
epsilon times the size of x.
And then multiply by
this factor over here.
And so we find the
statement up there.
So this calculation
formalizes the intuition
that if you have
epsilon regular pairs,
then they behave
like random settings
when it comes to counting
small patterns-- namely
that of a triangle.
So what can we use this for?
The next statement
I want to show you
is called a triangle
removal lemma.
So this is a somewhat
innocuous looking
statement that is
surprisingly tricky to prove.
And part of the development
of this regularity lemma was
to prove Szemerédi's-- to
the triangle removal lemma.
This was one of the early
applications of the regularity
lemma.
So it's due to Ruzsa and
Szemerédi back in the '70s.
Here's the statement.
For every epsilon
there exists a delta,
such that every graph of n
vertices with a small number
of triangles--
so a small number
of triangles means
a negligible fraction of all
the possible triples of vertices
are actual triangles.
So fewer than delta
n cubed triangles.
So if you have a graph with
a small number of triangles,
the question is, can you make
it triangle free by getting rid
of a small number of edges?
So actually, there was already
a problem on the first homework
set that is in that spirit.
So if you compare what I'm
doing here to the homework set,
you'll see that there
are different scales.
So fewer than delta
n cubed triangles
can be made triangle free
by removing epsilon n
squared edges.
So if you have a small
number of triangles,
you can get rid of
all the triangles
by removing a small
number of edges.
If I put it that
way, it actually
sounds kind of trivial.
You just get rid of
all the triangles.
But if you look at the scales
it's not trivial at all,
because there are only a
subcubic number of triangles.
So if you take out one
edge from each triangle,
maybe you got rid
of a lot of edges.
So this is a very innocent
looking statement,
but it's actually
incredibly deep and tricky.
Before jumping to the
proof, let me first
show you an equivalent
reformulation of the statement
that also helps you to think
about what this statement is
trying to say.
So the triangle removal lemma
can be equivalently stated
as saying that
every n vertex graph
with a subcubic
number of triangles--
so little o of n
cubed triangles--
can be made triangle free
by removing a subquadratic--
namely, little o of n squared--
number of edges.
So this is an
equivalent statement
to what I wrote above,
although it actually
takes some thought to figure
out what this is even saying
because everybody loves
using asymptotic notation,
but there is also
ambiguity with,
what do you mean by
asymptotic notation,
especially if it appears in
the hypothesis of a claim?
So what do you think
this statement means?
Can you write out
more of a full form?
I think of this
as a lazy version
of trying to say something.
So what do you mean by having
little o of n cubed triangles?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The
sequence of the graph.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
function has n and only n.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Great.
So I have a sequence of graphs.
And also, we can put
some functions in.
So I'll write down
the statement here,
but that's kind of the idea.
We're looking at not
just a single graph,
but we're looking at a sequence.
Another way to say this
is that for every function
fn, that is subcubic.
So for example, if f of n is
n cubed divided about log n,
there exists some function
g, which is subquadratic,
such that if you replace
the first one by f of n
and the second thing by g of n,
then this is a true statement.
And I'll leave it to
you as an exercise
in quantified
elimination, let's say,
to explain why these
two statements are
equivalent to each other.
I want to explain a recipe for
applying Szemerédi's regularity
lemma.
How does one use
the regularity lemma
to prove, well, statements
in graph theory?
The most standard applications
of regularity lemma
generally have the
following steps.
Let me call this a recipe.
And we'll see it a few times.
The first step is we apply
Szemerédi's regularity lemma
to obtain a partition.
So let me call the
first step partition.
In the second step, we look at
the partition that we obtained,
and we clean it up.
So in the partition, you have
some irregular pairs that
are undesirable to work with.
And there are some other
pairs that we'll see.
So in particular, if
your pair involves
edges that are fairly
sparse or subsets
of vertices that are
fairly small, then
maybe we don't
want to touch them
because they're kind of
not so good to deal with.
So we're going to
clean the graph
by removing edges in irregular
pairs and low density pairs.
And unless you're using the
version of regularity lemma
that allows you to
have equitable parts,
you also want to get rid of
edges where one of the parts
is too small.
And the third step,
I'll call this count.
Once you've cleaned up
the regularity partition,
say, well, let's try
to find some patterns.
If you find one pattern
in the cleaned graph--
and we can use the counting
lemma to find lots of patterns.
Here, for the purpose of
triangle removal lemma
and what we've
been doing so far,
pattern just means a triangle.
So we're going to use the
triangle counting lemma to find
us lots of triangles.
So we'll see the
details in a bit.
But if we run through
the strategy--
you give me a graph.
Let's say, starting from
the triangle removal lemma,
it has a small
number of triangles.
You apply the
partition, clean it up,
and I claim this
cleaning removes
a small number of edges.
And it should result in
a triangle free graph
because if it did not result
in a triangle free graph, then
there's some triangle.
And from that triangle I can
apply the triangle counting
lemma to get lots of triangles.
And that would
violate the hypothesis
of the triangle removal lemma.
So that's how the
proof is going to go.
So I want to take
a very quick break.
And then when we
come back, we'll
see the details of how to
apply the irregularity lemma.
Are there any questions so far?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when
we're removing edges
in one of the [INAUDIBLE],,
is that too small?
Can we do that for every
vertex, or is it too small?
PROFESSOR: So you're
asking about what
happens when we remove
vertexes that are too small.
You will see in the
details of the proof.
So hold on to that
question for a bit.
More questions.
OK.
So let's see the proof of
the triangle removal lemma.
So the first step is to apply
Szemerédi's regularity lemma
and find a partition.
So we'll find a partition
that's epsilon over 4 regular.
So here, epsilon
is the same epsilon
in the statement-- in the top
statement-- of the triangle
removal lemma.
In the second step,
let's clean the graph
by removing all edges in--
so we are going to get
rid of edges between--
OK.
So let me do it this way.
So all edges between
the vi and the vj
whenever vi and vj is
not epsilon regular.
Get rid of the edges
between irregular parts.
AUDIENCE: Epsilon
over 4 regular.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Epsilon
over 4 regular.
PROFESSOR: Epsilon
Thank you.
Also, between parts where the
edge density is too small--
if the edge density is
less than epsilon over 2,
get rid of those edges.
And if one of the
two vertex sets
has size too small--
and here, too small
means epsilon over 4M
times the size of n.
So here-- OK.
So let me use big M for
the number of parts.
So that's the M that comes
out of Szemerédi's regularity
lemma.
If you like, some of the
vertex sets can be empty.
It doesn't change the proof.
And n is the number of
vertices in the graph.
And this step, you don't
really need the step
if your regular
partition is equitable.
So let's see how many
vertices-- how many edges
have we gotten rid of.
We want to show that we're
not deleting too many edges.
In the first step--
so the number of deleted edges.
In the first step, you see that
the number of edges deleted
is at most the sum of product of
vi vj when you sum over ij such
that this pair is not epsilon
regular or epsilon 4 regular.
Epsilon over 4 regular.
By the definition of an
epsilon regular partition,
the sum here is at most
epsilon over 4 times n squared.
In the second step, I'm getting
rid of low density pairs.
By the virtue of them
being low density,
I'm not removing so many edges.
So at most epsilon over
2 times n squared edges
I'm getting rid of.
In the third part, you see every
time I take a very small piece,
every vertex here is adjacent
to at most n vertices.
So the number of such
things, such edges
I'm getting rid of
in the last step
is at most this number times a
number of parts M then times n.
So it's at most epsilon
over 4 times n squared.
So here I'm telling
you how many edges
I've deleted in each step.
And in total, putting
them together,
we see that we get rid of at
most epsilon n squared edges
from this graph.
So that's the cleaning step.
So we cleaned up the graph
by getting rid of low density
pairs, getting rid of irregular
pairs, and small vertex s.
Now suppose, after
this cleaning,
some triangles still remains.
So we're now onto
the third step.
So suppose some
triangle remains.
So where could
this triangle sit?
Has to be between three parts--
vi, vj, and vk.
I, j, and k, they don't
have to be distinct.
So the argument will be OK
if some of them are the same,
but it's easier to draw
if they're all different.
So I have some
triangle, like that.
Because these edges have not
yet been deleted in the cleaning
step, I know that the vertex
sets are not too small,
the edge densities
are not too small,
and they are all
regular with each other.
So here, each pair in vi, vj,
vk is epsilon over 4 regular
and have edge density
at least epsilon over 2.
And now we apply the
triangle counting lemma,
and we find that the
number of triangles
with one vertex in
vi, one vertex in vj,
one vertex in the vk is at
least this quantity here.
So that's a correction factor.
So 1 over this 2 epsilon.
And then a bunch of densities--
so densities are not too small.
So I have at least
epsilon over 4 n
cubed multiplied by the
sizes of the vertex sets.
Now I know that--
use the fact that these part
sizes are not too small.
So I have that.
Just in case, if i, j, and
k happen to be the same,
or two of them happen
to be the same,
I might overcount the number
of triangles a little bit.
But at most, you overcount
by a factor of 6.
So that's OK.
So if you're worried
about that, put
the 1 over 6 factor in, just
in case i, j, k not distinct.
Or if you like, in the
cleaning step, you can--
if you apply the equitable
version of the regularity
lemma, you can also get rid
of edges inside the parts.
But there are many
ways to do this.
It's not an important step.
Now, this quantity, let
me set it to be delta.
You see, delta is a
function of epsilon
because M is a
function of epsilon.
So now, looking back
at the statement,
you see for every epsilon
there exists a delta, such
that if your graph has fewer
than delta n cubed triangles,
then let me get rid
of all those edges.
I've gotten rid of fewer
than epsilon n squared edges,
and the remaining graph
should be triangle free.
Because if it were
not triangle free,
then I can find some triangle.
And that will lead to
a lot more triangles.
So for example, if you
set this as delta over 2,
then this will give you 2
delta n cubed triangles.
Therefore, it would
contradict the hypothesis.
And that finishes the proof
of the triangle removal lemma,
saying that thus the resulting
graph is triangle free.
So that's the proof of the
triangle removal lemma.
So let me recap.
We start with a graph, apply
Szemerédi's regularity lemma,
and clean up the regularity
partition by getting rid of low
density pairs, getting
rid of irregular pairs,
and getting rid of edges
touching a very small vertex
set.
And I claim that the resulting
graph, after cleaning up,
should be triangle free.
Because if it were not triangle
free and I find some triangle,
then I should be able to use
that triple of vertex sets,
combined with a
triangle counting lemma,
to produce a lot
more triangles and.
That would violate the
hypothesis of the theorem.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where are you using
that there exists a triangle?
PROFESSOR: Ah, great.
So question is, where am I
using there exists a triangle?
If there were no
triangles, then we're done.
So the purpose of the triangle--
the claim in the triangle
removal lemma is that you
can get rid of all triangles
by removing at most
epsilon n squared edges.
AUDIENCE: So say we
did that, and now--
why does this not prove that
we still have triangles?
PROFESSOR: Can you say
your question again?
AUDIENCE: So say we've removed
everything by our cleaning
step, and we've removed
epsilon n squared edges,
why does this logic
not prove that we still
have delta n cubed triangles.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let me try to
answer your question.
So why does this proof
show that you still
have delta n cubed triangles?
So I only set delta at the end.
But of course, you
can also set delta
in the beginning of this proof.
So I'm saying that
you do the step.
You get rid of epsilon
n squared edges.
And now I claim,
after the step--
so I claim the remaining
graph is triangle free.
If it were not triangle
free, then, well,
it has some triangle.
Then the triangle
counting lemma would tell
me there are lots of triangles.
And that would
contradict the hypothesis
where we assume that
this graph G has
a small number of triangles.
AUDIENCE: So if
there is no triangle,
then we've removed edges between
vi, vj, or vi, vk, or vj,
vk for any three i, j, k.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
So we're saying, if you do
not have any triangles-- well,
after the cleaning
step, we have gotten rid
of all the edges
between the bad pairs.
And I'm claiming that
there is no configuration
like this left.
And this is the proof because
if you have some configuration
where you did not delete the
edges between these three
parts, then you
should be able to get
a lot more triangles from
the triangle counting lemma.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What if
there were lots
of triangles inside each
individual vi, vj, vk?
PROFESSOR: You asked
me, what happens
if there were a lot of triangles
inside each vi, vj, vk?
So that is fine.
If you find some triangle--
so this picture,
i, j, or k, they
do not have to be distinct.
So the same proof works if
i, j, and k, some of them
are equal to each other.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] but,
I don't really understand
why-- isn't delta over 2 there?
PROFESSOR: So you're asking,
why did I put the delta over 2?
Just because I put less
than or equal to delta.
If I put strictly
less than delta,
then I don't need
a delta over 2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
delta over 2 or 2 delta.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Don't worry about it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a way to generalize
the triangle counting
lemma to a general graph?
PROFESSOR: OK.
You're asking, is there
a way to generalize
the triangle counting
lemma to a general graph?
So yes.
We will see that not today
but I think next time.
Any more questions?
Great.
So why do people care about
the triangle removal lemma?
So it's a nice, maybe somewhat
unintuitive statement.
But there was a very good
reason why the statement was
formulated, and
it's because you can
use it to prove Roth's theorem.
So that's what I
want to explain,
how to connect this
graph theoretic statement
to a statement about
three-term AP--
three AP-free subsets
of the integers.
This goes back to the very
connection between graph theory
and additive combinatorics
that I highlighted
in the first lecture.
First, let me state a corollary
of the triangle removal lemma--
namely, that if you have an
n vertex graph G, where--
so if G is n vertex, and
every edge is in exactly one
triangle, then the
number of edges of G
is little o of n squared.
These are actually
kind of strange graphs.
Every edge is in
exactly one triangle.
OK.
Well, the number
of triangles in G--
ever edge is in
exactly one triangle.
So the number of triangles
in G is the number
of edges divided by 3.
The number of edges
is at most n squared.
So this quantity is at
most quadratic order,
which in particular is
little o of n cubed.
And thus the triangle
removal lemma
tells us that G can
be made triangle
free by removing little
o of n squared edges.
On the other hand,
since every edge
is in exactly one
triangle, well,
how many edges do you
need to remove to get rid
of all the triangles?
Well, I need to remove at
least a third of the edges.
I need to remove at
least a third of edges
to make G triangle free.
Putting these two
claims together,
we see that the
number of edges of G
must be little o of n squared.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Are there not more
elementary ways to prove this?
PROFESSOR: Great.
Question is, are there not more
elementary ways to prove this?
Let me make some
comments about that.
So the short answer
is, yes but not really.
And really, the answer is no.
[LAUGHTER]
So you can ask, what
about quantitative bounds?
Because what is more elementary,
what is less elementary
is kind of subjective.
But quantitative
bounds, something
that is very concrete.
It's hard to argue.
So if you look at the triangle
removal lemma, you can ask,
how is the dependence
of delta on epsilon?
So what does the proof give you?
Where's the bottleneck?
The bottleneck is always
in the application
of Szemerédi's regularity
lemma-- namely in this M.
So none of the other
epsilons really matter.
It's this M that kills you in
terms of quantitative bounds.
So in triangle removal lemma,
this proof gives 1 over delta.
So you can take 1 over delta
being a tower of twos of height
at most polynomial
in 1 over epsilon.
So that is your different proof.
Well, the best known
bound due to Fox
is that you can
replace this height
by a different height that
is at most essentially
logarithmic in 1 over epsilon.
Still a tower of twos.
So we've changed some
really big number
to another, but slightly
smaller, really big number.
So this is still an
astronomical number
for any reasonable epsilon.
And in terms of that corollary,
basically the only known proof
goes through the
triangle removal lemma.
Currently, we do not know any
other approach to this problem.
And you'll see later on
that, well, what's the best
thing that we can hope for?
So it is quite possible that
there are other proofs that
are yet to be found.
So that's actually--
people believe this,
that this is not
the right proof,
that maybe there's some
other way to do this.
And the best lower bound, which
we'll see either later today
or next time, shows that we
cannot do better than 1 over
epsilon being essentially just a
little bit more than polynomial
in epsilon.
So epsilon raised
to something that is
logarithmic in 1 over epsilon.
So you can think
of this as very--
it's a little bit bigger than
polynomial in 1 over epsilon
but not that much bigger than
polynomial in 1 over epsilon.
So there is a very big
gap in our knowledge
on what is the right dependence
between epsilon and delta
in the triangle removal lemma.
And that's one of the--
it's a major open problem
in extremal combinatorics
to close this gap.
Other questions?
All right.
So let's prove Roth's theorem.
So let me remind you that
Roth's theorem, which
we saw in the very
first lecture,
says that if you
have a subset of 1
through n that is free
of three-term arithmetic
progressions, then the size
of the set must be sublinear.
So what does this have to do
with a triangle removal lemma?
So if you remember
the first lecture,
maybe the connection
shouldn't be so surprising.
What we will do is we
will set up a graph,
starting from some
arithmetic sets such
that the graph encodes some
arithmetic information--
in particular, the three-term
APs in your graph, in the set,
correspond to the
triangles in the graph.
So let's set up this graph.
It will be helpful to view A
not as a subset of the integers.
It'll just be more
convenient to view it
as a subset of a cyclic group.
Because I don't have to worry
about edge cases so much when
you're working a cyclic group.
Here I take M to be 2N plus 1.
So having it odd makes
my life a bit simpler.
Then if A is three AP free
subset of 1 through n,
then I claim that A now sitting
inside this cyclic group
is also three AP free.
So it's a subset of Z mod n.
And what we will do is that we
will set up a certain graph.
So we will set up a
tripartite graph, x, y, z.
And here, x, y, and
z are going to be
M elements whose
vertices are represented
by elements of Z mod n.
And I need to tell you what
are the edges of this graph.
So here are the edges.
I'm putting an edge between
vertex x and y if and only
if y minus x is an element of A.
So it's a rule for how
to put in the edges.
And this is basically a Cayley
graph, a bipartite variant
of a Cayley graph.
Likewise, I put an
edge between x and z.
So let me put x down
here and y up there.
So let me put in the edge
between y and z if and only
if z minus y is an element of A.
And for the very last pair, it's
similar but slightly different.
I'm putting that edge if and
only if z minus x divided by 2
is an element of A. Because
we're in an odd cyclic group
I can divide by 2.
So this is a graph.
So starting with
a set A I give you
this rule for constructing
this tripartite graph.
And the question
now is, what are
the triangles in this graph?
If the vertices x, y, z is
a triangle, then these three
numbers by definition,
because of the edges--
because they're all edges
in this graph, these three
numbers, they all lie in A.
But now notice that
these three numbers,
they form a three-term
arithmetic progression
because the middle element is
the average of the two others.
But we said that A is a
set that is three AP free.
Has no three-term
arithmetic progression.
So what must be the case?
So A is 3 AP free.
But you can still have three
APs using the same element
three times.
So all the three-term
arithmetic progressions
must be of that form.
So these three numbers must
then equal to each other.
And in particular, you see
that if you select x and y,
it determines z.
This equality here is the
same as saying that x, y,
and z they themselves form
a three AP in Z mod nz.
So this is precisely
the description
of all the triangles
in the graph.
So all the triangles
in the graph G
are precisely x, y,
z, where x, y, and z
form a three-term
arithmetic progression.
And in particular, every edge of
G lies in exactly one triangle.
You give me an edge--
for example, xy--
I complete it two a
three AP, x, y, z.
And that's the triangle.
And that's the unique triangle
that the edge sits in.
And likewise, if you
give me xz or yz,
I can produce for you
a unique triangle.
So we have this graph.
It has this property that
every edge lies in exactly one
triangle, so we can
apply the corollary
up there to deduce a bound
on the total number of edges.
Well, how many edges are there?
On one hand, we see that because
it's a Cayley graph, each
of the three parts--
there are three parts here.
Each of the three parts,
if I start with any vertex,
I have A edges coming out of
that vertex to the next part
by the construction.
On the other hand,
by the corollary
up there, the
number of edges has
to be little o of M squared.
And because M is
essentially twice n,
we obtain that the size
of A is little o of M.
And that proves Roth's theorem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you
explain one more time
why every edge is in
exactly one triangle?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the question is, why is every
edge in exactly one triangle?
So you know what
all the edges are.
So this is a description
of what all the edges are.
And what are all the triangles.
Well, x, y, z is a triangle
precisely when these three
expressions all lie in A.
But note that these three
expressions, they
form a three AP
because the middle term is
the average of the two others.
So x, y, z is the
triangle if and only
if this equation is true.
And this equation is
true if and only if x,
y, z form a three AP in Z mod n.
So if you just read out this
equation, I give you x and y.
So what is z?
So all the triangles in x, y,
z are precisely given by three
APs, where one of the
differences y minus x is in A.
OK.
So I give you an edge.
For example, xy, such
that y minus z is in A.
And I claim there's a
unique z that completes
this edge to a triangle.
Well, it tells you
what that z is.
z has to be the
element in Z mod m
that completes x
and y to a three AP.
Namely, z is the solution
to this equation.
No other z can work.
And you can check
that z indeed works
and that all the
remaining pairs are edges.
So it's something you can check.
Any more questions?
So starting with the set
A that is three AP free,
we set up this graph
with a property
that every edge lies in
exactly one triangle.
And the one triangle basically
corresponds to the fact
that you always have these
trivial three APs repeating
the same element three times.
And then, by applying this
corollary of the triangle
removal lemma, we
deduce that the number
of edges in the graph
must be subquadratic.
So then the size of
A must be sublinear.
And that proves Roth's theorem.
So we did quite a bit of work
in proving this theorem--
Szemerédi's regularity lemma,
counting lemma, removal lemma,
and then we set up this graph.
So it's not an easy theorem.
Later in the course, we'll
see a different proof
of Roth's theorem that goes
through Fourier analysis.
That will look
somewhat different,
but it will have similar themes.
So we'll also have
this theme comparing
structure and pseudorandomness,
which comes up in the proof--
in the statement and proof of
Szemerédi's graph regularity
lemma.
So there, it's really
about understanding
what is the structure of the
graph in terms of decomposition
into parts that
look pseudorandom.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You called the
graph the Cayley graph.
Why?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So question is, why do I call
this graph the Cayley graph?
So usually the Cayley
graph refers to a graph
where I give you a group, and I
give you a subset of the group,
and I connect two elements if,
let's say, their difference
lies in my subset.
This basically has that form.
So it's not exactly what
people mean by a Cayley graph,
but it has that spirit.
Any more questions?
OK.
So earlier I talked about bounds
for triangle removal lemma.
So what about bounds
for Roth's theorem?
We do know somewhat better
bounds for Roth's theorem
compared to this proof.
Somehow it's a nice proof, it's
a nice graph, theoretic proof,
but it doesn't give
you very good bounds.
It gives you bounds that decay
very poorly as a function of n.
Actually, what does it give
you as a function of n?
If you were to replace this
little o by a function of n
according to this proof,
what would you get?
I'm basically asking,
what is the inverse
of the function where
you input some number
and it gives you a tower
of exponentials of height
with that input?
It's called a log star.
So the log star--
so this is essentially N
over the log star of N.
So the log star
basically is the number
of times you have to take the
logarithm to get you below 1.
So that's the log star.
And there's a saying
that the log star, we
know that it grows to
infinity, but it has never
been observed to do so.
It's extremely slowly
growing function.
Any more questions?
So I want to--
so next time I want to show
you a construction that
gives you a--
so next time I will
show you a construction
that gives you a subset A
of n that is fairly large.
So you might ask, OK, so
you have this upper bound,
but what should the truth be?
And here's more or less
the state of knowledge.
So best bounds of
Roth's theorem.
Basically, the best bounds have
the form N divided by basically
log N raised to power
1 plus little o1.
The precise bounds are
of the form N over log N,
and then there's some
extra log-log factors.
But let's not worry about that.
The best lower bounds--
so we'll see this next time.
So there exists subsets
of 1 through N such
that the size of A is
at least e to the--
so N times-- so first, let
me say it's pretty close to--
the exponent is as
close to 1 as you wish.
So there exists as A
such that the size of A
is N to the 1 minus little o1.
And already, this
fact is an indication
of the difficulty of the
problem because if you
could prove Roth's theorem
through some fairly
elementary
techniques, like using
a Cauchy-Schwarz a bunch
of times for instance,
then experience tells
us that you probably
expect some bound that's
power saving, replacing
the 1 by some smaller number.
But that's not the case.
And the fact that
that's not the case
is already indication
of the difficulty
of this upper bound
of Roth's theorem,
even getting a little o.
So you don't expect there
to be simple proofs getting
the little o.
The bound that we'll
see next time--
so we'll see a construction
which gives you
a bound that is of this form.
So it's maybe a little
bit hard to think
about how quickly
this function grows,
but I'll let you think about it.
Now, how does this--
so let's look at
this corollary here.
Can you see a way to
construct a graph which
has lots of edges, such that
every edge lies in exactly one
triangle?
So we did this
connection showing
how to use this corollary
to prove Roth's theorem.
But you can run the
same connection.
So starting from
this three AP free A,
we can use that construction
to build a graph
n, such that a graph of n
vertices with essentially
order of n times the size
of A number of edges, such
that every edge lies in
exactly one triangle.
So you run the
same construction.
And this is actually
more or less
the only way that we know how
to construct such graphs that
are fairly dense.
So on one hand--
basically what I said earlier.
On one hand, you have
this upper bound,
which is given by the proof of
using Szemerédi's regularity
lemma that gives you a tower
in the upper bound of 1 over
delta.
And if you use this construction
here of three AP free
set to construct the graph, you
get this lower bound on delta,
which is quasipolynomial.
And that's more or
less that we know.
And there's a major open
problem to close these two gaps.
Any more questions?
So I want to give you a plan
on what's coming up ahead.
So today we saw one application
of Szemerédi's regularity
lemma--
namely, the triangle
removal lemma,
which has this application
to Roth's theorem.
So we've seen our first
proof of Roth's theorem.
And next lecture, and
the next couple lectures,
I want to show you a few
extensions and applications
of Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
So one of the
questions today was,
we knew how to count
the triangles, but what
about other graphs?
And as you can imagine, if
you can count triangles,
then the other
graphs should also
be doable using the same ideas.
And we'll do that.
So we'll see how to
count other graphs.
And we'll give you a--
well, I'll give you a proof
of the Erdos-Stone-Simonovits
theorem that we did not prove in
the first part of this course.
So it gives you an upper
bound on the extremal number
of a graph H that depends only
on the chromatic number of H.
So we'll do that.
And then I'll also mention,
although not prove,
some extensions
of the regularity
lemma to other settings,
such as to hypergraphs.
And what that's
useful for is that it
will allow us to
deduce generalizations
of Roth's theorem to longer
arithmetic progressions.
Proving Szemerédi's theorem.
So one way to deduce Szemerédi's
theorem is to use a hypergraph
removal lemma--
the hypergraph extension
of the graph removal lemma,
the triangle removal
lemma that we saw today.
It would also let us
derive higher dimensional
generalizations
of these theorems.
So it's a very powerful tool.
And actually, the
hypergraph removal lemma,
as mentioned in the
very first lecture,
it's a very difficult extension
of the graph removal lemma.
And the hypergraph
regularity lemma,
which can be used to prove
the hypergraph removal lemma,
is a difficult extension of
the graph regularity lemma.
So we'll see that in
the next few lectures.